welcome back to special report let's
take a look at where things stand in
ukraine tonight this is a map of russian
occupied territories controlled areas as
of yesterday into today the key point
here is that it is around the cities
not in the cities and you can see this
there's a city down here maripole
basically all of these cities are
surrounded in one way or another by
russian forces kharkiv is getting
bombarded
by
shelling
by missiles not guided missiles it has
changed according to pentagon officials
and u.s intelligence it has gone into
this siege mode
for the russians and unfortunately looks
a little bit like grozny some bombing in
kiev as well as shelling in maripole
a number of engagements on the ground
but it is not complete control of these
big cities which is a testament to the
ukrainian defense forces we've been
talking a lot about this russian convoy
40 miles long it is stalled according to
u.s intelligence if you take a look at
here this is kiev proper
where downtown is right about there
this is that convoy going all the way up
passive ankive all the way up now they
have supply issues they're essentially
stalled it's a long convo convoy of
armored vehicles and tanks they are
getting supplies we're told and there is
a kind of resupply effort and they're
reorganizing but right now
it's essentially on hold
and that is a good thing for the
ukrainians each day that that happens
is a good day
in the same moment
uh and here's kiev right here
you are having about 660 to 680 000
refugees
getting out of ukraine towards poland
and that is clogging that route
and at the same time you're getting some
coming into the country to fight
alongside the ukrainian forces that is a
new phenomena and they're doing so with
weapons from countries around the globe
these are all the countries sending
weapons to ukraine
in one way or another the us among them
the biggest weapon of choice is the
javelin anti-armor anti-tank missile
that's being used so effectively by
ukrainian defense forces but the
question is can they get it fast enough
can they hold the russians off before
they get into the city of kiev and take
out that government and president
zielinski hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else